der Glacier Express in der Schweiz fährt
auf einer der beeindruckendsten
Zugstrecken überhaupt weltweit und ich
habe ihn für euch getestet
selbstverständlich habe ich aber nicht
irgendeinen Platz reserviert sondern den
teuersten und besten den man bekommen
konnte excellence class für 415 € pro
Person für 6 Stunden Fahrt ob sich das
lohnt finden wir jetzt gemeinsam heraus
die erste Besonderheit der Zug besteht
quasi komplett aus Glas damit man auch
was von der Kulisse und dieser schönen
Zugstrecke hat während ich also auf über
2000 Metern Höhe über 291 Brücken und
durch 91 Tunnel gefahren bin konnte ich
die exzellenzglas in vollen Zügen
genießen auf der gesamten Reise gab es
eine Weinbegleitung die auf die Region
und das vorzügliche drei Gänge Menü
abgestimmt war und alle weiteren
Getränke waren selbstverständlich im
Preis inbegriffen tatsächlich haben wir
Bein gereicht bekommen der immer zu den
Standorten gepasst hat wo wir uns gerade
mit dem Zug befunden haben was ich sehr
nice fand außerdem das Besondere am drei
Gänge Menü im Gegensatz zu einer
Business oder first class in dem
Flugzeug gab es im Zug eine echte Küche
in der das Essen richtig frisch
zubereitet wurde aber nicht nur das
Essen sondern auch die Sitze konnten mit
einer Business Class mehr als nur
mithalten